[Musique]
Madeleine blémorin Michel c'est Auger
bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir On va se parler de la COP15 dans
une seconde mais d'abord on a vu ça en
fin de semaine et je vous le remonte
carré price il y aurait eu un débat sur
les armes à feu de toute façon les
conservateurs ne sont pas contents des
amendements déposés par les libéraux
mais quand même ça a donné une
proportion à ce débat j'aime ma famille
j'aime mon pays je vous lisais en début
d'émission je me soucie de mon prochain
je ne suis pas un criminel je soutiens
la Coalition pour les armes à feu et
garder mes armes de chasse merci
Monsieur poignet qui a répondu un peu de
temps après carry a tout à fait raison
la chasse est une grande tradition
canadienne les tentatives de Trudeau
d'interdire les fusils de chasse sont
une attaque contre les populations
rurales et autochtones et là il y a une
pétition qui circule je vous fais
entendre avant de vous entendre monsieur
Trudeau
il en réalité
c'est que on va faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour garder les Canadiens en
sécurité tout en respectant les
chasseurs et ceux qui utilisent des
armes à feu de façon responsable mais il
y a certains modèles qu'on ne peut pas
permettre dans notre pays parce qu'ils
ont été créés pour tuer le plus grand
nombre de gens le plus rapidement
possible mais on va continuer d'aller de
l'avant pour protéger les communautés et
on va repousser contre ces politiciens
conservateurs qui travaillent avec le
lobby des armes à feu et qui veulent
ramener le droit de posséder des armes
de style à soupe dans ce pays
pourquoi le gouvernement ne veut-il pas
aider à combattre la vraie criminalité
au lieu de cibler nos chasseurs et nos
fermiers
c'est quelqu'un d'important qui est
écouté et malheureusement puis je veux
pas lui prêter d'intention mais ça
réaction rajoute la confusion les
Canadiens ce qu'ils veulent puis ça fait
de nombreuses années ils veulent qu'on
réduise le nombre d'armes en circulation
la réduction des armes de style d'assaut
et pas quelque chose qui est contre
l'intention des Canadiens
ce qui fait Madeleine que le débat
repart c'est aussi que effectivement
puis monsieur Trudeau l'a reconnu il y a
certaines armes qui sont maintenant
touchées qui seraient maintenant
prohibées qui sont associés
effectivement davantage à la chasse là
on en montre une les loin on a montré
une SAS moi je connais rien la dent mais
bref on voit ça un exemple oui les
libéraux vont vous dire par exemple que
l'arme que Kary price avait sur sa photo
ne serait pas une arme qui deviendrait
prohibée il dit il y a beaucoup les
libéraux disent il y a beaucoup de
désinformations dans ce débat là on est
dans un débat qui est compliqué
justement parce que toutes sortes de
type d'armes des forces différentes un
des calibres différents le nombre de
munitions par cartouche qui est
différent donc voyez-vous on est dans
des techniques parfois et ça devient
difficile de s'y retrouver les libéraux
avaient d'abord instauré une liste
d'armes d'assaut militaire qui serait
interdite puis ils ont réalisé que
l'industrie pouvait contourner la liste
en changeant une petite chose sur
l'arbre changeant le nom et on
contournait comme ça les nouvelles
règles du gouvernement d'où cette idée
délibéraux d'arrivée avec une définition
des armes qui seraient désormais
interdites et mais cette définition là
est arrivée à minuit moins 5 et ce qui
fait réagir d'autant plus les parties
d'opposition les conservateurs et là
c'est là qu'on est rendu dans cette idée
de d'un gouvernement qui est peut-être
arrivé à la toute dernière minute et
peut donner l'impression maintenant
d'avoir quelque chose à cacher ou de ne
pas faire le débat jusqu'à la fin parce
que
des camps différents dans ce débat là
c'est une évidence mais même ce Trudeau
reconnaissait aujourd'hui que
peut-être que certaines armes touchées
qui n'auraient pas du lait donc ouvrir
cette porte là c'est rouvrir le débat
pas forcément
ce qu'il a fait aujourd'hui c'est assez
clairement de dire écoutez on va revoir
les amendements qu'on vient d'apporter
là peut-être qu'on est allé un petit peu
trop loin peut-être qu'il y en a qu'on
peut enlever tout ça c'est un débat
éternel sur Canada après les villes et
les régions rurales empêchait et
il faut être très prudent parce que ces
gens-là très bien organisé et qui a des
relais politiques très importants de
vues supérieur alors donc il faut que
dans l'exécution ce soit parfait pour
pas donner l'impression qu'on est en
train de passer des petites vitres et
arriver à la fin du débat comme ça avec
des amendements ça donne toujours cette
impression là qu'on le veuille ou non
alors je dis pas que les gens sont de
mauvaise foi après pas du tout mais à un
moment donné il faut être très très
précis dans l'exécution c'est ça que le
gouvernement n'a pas fait là il est
obligé vous êtes obligé de reculer la
catastrophe sur un certain nombre de
mesures qui voulaient prendre je sais
pas Patrice vous souvenez lors de la
dernière campagne électorale c'était
eren auto à l'époque qui était chef du
Parti conservateur et il avait apposé un
risque dans sa plateforme électorale
parce qu'il y avait une phrase et qui
avait finalement des rats dérailler une
partie de la campagne conservatrice et
ça portait justement sur la liste
d'armes qui seraient prohibées et là les
libéraux accusaient les conservateurs
d'avoir quelque chose à cacher pendant
des jours les conservateurs se faisaient
questionner là-dessus moi j'ai
l'impression que les libéraux sont un
petit peu l'arrosage dans cette
histoire-là eux aussi se sont fait
prendre au jeu de pas laisser
suffisamment
le débat se faire de façon assez
transparente justement et donnant
l'impression comme ça que peut-être des
aspects du débat qui sont pas
complètement ouverts et transparent et
Michel vous le dites bien c'est un débat
éternel au Canada entre les régions
rurales et les villes et que quelqu'un
avec la notoriété
de Carrey price
choisissent son camp ça libère aussi les
paroles il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent enfin beaucoup de gens il y a des
gens qui écrivent qui disent nous on est
chasseur on a tel type d'arbres on veut
pas faire de crème on veut pouvoir
chasser en pelle
oui et c'est tout à fait légitime la
chasse c'est moi
c'est vrai en même temps est-ce qu'on a
besoin d'un semi-automatique pour
chasser je disais c'est ça qui disait
l'oiseau qui arrive tu es pas mal mieux
que nous subir automatique ok là mais
peut-être qu'en terme de sécurité
publique c'est peut-être pas ça le
meilleur argument alors il faut balancer
tout ça il faut et puis il faut prendre
le temps de bien le faire puis là c'est
ça qui est dommage dans cette chose là
c'est que les gouvernements aiment pas
aller
légiférer sur les sur les armes à feu
parce qu'ils savent le genre de débat
émotif qui vont
susciter et puis là ben
on va être obligé peut-être de retirer
les choses assez de les ramener plus
tard c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'une
chance ratée là ouais Madeleine donc il
y aura amendement aux amendements c'est
ce qu'on comprend oui le prochain la
prochaine réunion du comité
parlementaire qui se penche là dessus
c'est demain là si je comprends bien
entre les
québécois qui était allié au départ sur
cette question là on essaie de
s'arranger pour voir bon est-ce qu'on
peut allonger les séances faire revenir
des témoins pour entendre justement
cette nouvelle définition de ce qui
serait une arme prohibée mais sur la
question de est-ce que c'est une bonne
stratégie de de sécurité publique il est
là aussi le débat parce que en ce moment
la criminalité par armes à feu elle est
en augmentation au pays donc les
libéraux peuvent dire il faut donc
contrôler les armes davantage alors que
les conservateurs vont dire au libéraux
vous vous y prenez mal il faut plutôt
s'attaquer au trafic d'armes aux
frontières de rue justement alors le
débat il se fait là aussi un mot sur la
coque 15
ce matin donc j'ai rencontré le ministre
québécois qui dit qui me disait
d'ailleurs que
avec Steven gilbaud ils ont la les mêmes
objectifs à cette COP15 sur la
biodiversité Jean Lemire qui sera
délégué aussi du Québec dans la
délégation canadienne
c'est quand même un rendez-vous et tous
ceux à qui on parle nous disent
Madeleine c'est un rendez-vous
extrêmement important c'est un peu la
dernière chance et 10 prochaines années
pour qu'on arrive à un accord plus
contraignant oui on parle beaucoup plus
des coques sur les changements
climatiques on en conviendra mais là
tout d'un coup on sent qu'il y a quand
même une certaine momentum ne s'est pas
le bon mot mais un certain élan sur la
biodiversité aussi comme si cette
idée-là percol que pour faire la lutte
contre les changements climatiques il
faut se préoccuper de biodiversité et
vice-versa les objectifs seront
ambitieux on est encore loin d'avoir un
accord qui est final là on voyait tout
ce qui reste encore à régler c'est
encore énorme mais parfois il y a une
magie qui s'opère dans les cops donc
peut-être qu'on arrivera à quelque chose
c'est la Chine encore qui qui préside
avec le Canada cette copla il semble que
la Chine est engagée dans une discussion
là et quand même participe passé
activement même si elle pouvait pas être
l'autre de la COP en raison de la covid
elle serait quand même engagée dans ces
dans ces démarches là exactement ça
devait vous avez raison de le souligner
étranger les contenus de la covid le
Canada a offert de tenir l'événement à
Montréal et ça s'est organisé assez vite
c'est vraiment une forteresse en passant
le Michel c'est c'est digne des plus
gros G20 que j'ai vu envers même plus
que sur Paris cadre c'est un territoire
en hygiène maintenant mais sur le fond
Michel effectivement les gens sont
mélangés souvent mais là on a
l'impression que de plus en plus de gens
savent que c'est quelque chose
d'important que c'est la biodiversité
que c'est les espèces animales que c'est
les plans que c'est ce qui c'est la vie
quoi
c'est ça sauf que c'est comme là sont
jusqu'à un certain point je posais que
les autres le sont pas mais plus
compliquées que celles sur le
réchauffement climatique là on voit
littéralement dans des affaires comme
une zonage on va littéralement dans des
choses qui touchent les gens directement
et qui touchent la gouvernance au niveau
municipal etc alors c'est ça c'est un
moment donné vous avez parlé de la
fameuse je vais mettre on va pas passer
le centre commercial à cause de la cause
d'une grenouille les gens
souvent des choses comme ça alors ça
c'est compliqué parce que les
ramifications sont vraiment
très étendu et vont jusqu'à jusqu'au
niveau local évidemment puis touche les
gens très très directement alors souvent
les politiciens vont avoir un peu peur
de ça
ensemble les grandes décisions ils sont
d'accord
la question de la politique de la
biodiversité on sent qu'il y a un grand
clivage pour si de la lutte contre les
changements climatiques sur la scène
fédéral par exemple on s'entend pas en
conservateur et libéraux il semble y
avoir moins de division sur la
biodiversité comme si on s'entendait
davantage comme si on ciblait moins
l'industrie pétrolière donc moins
l'Alberta la Saskatchewan donc c'est un
défi qui est énorme mais qui est
différent d'une certaine façon d'un
point de vue politique et pour
simplifier disons que l'objectif c'est
de préserver 30% du territoire d'ici
2030 préservés dans l'état le plus
naturel possible soit en achetant des
terres soit en faisant des désaccords
voilà l'objectif de cette COP on verra
merci à vous deux pour ce soir le pan
dis à très bientôt au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI